a quadratic polynomial is of the form ax
squared plus BX plus C so something like
x squared plus 3x plus 2 how do we
factorize this this is in the ax squared
plus BX plus C form a is the coefficient
of x squared it's 1 B is the coefficient
of x and it equals 3 and C is the
constant which equals 2 this is the
basic form of a quadratic polynomial
where a B and C could take different
numerical values look at the expression
we are given we cannot factorize it
using any identity as the Blaster is not
in squared form so how do we reduce this
to its factors
we use a simple technique of splitting
the coefficient of the middle term here
we would split 3x in such a way that it
would help us factorize using grouping
but we cannot just split it in any way
we wish there's an interesting technique
which helps us split the coefficient of
the middle term we assume that the
coefficient 3 has to be split into two
numbers n1 and n2 the first condition
says that n 1 plus n 2 should be equal
to B in this case 3 the two numbers
should add up to 3 and the next
condition says that the product of the
two numbers should equal the product of
a and C as a is 1 and C is 2 this
product will equal 2 that's it only
these two conditions which two numbers
do you think would satisfy these two
conditions if you would have tried a few
combinations you would have got the two
numbers as 1 and 2 1 plus 2 is 3 and 1
times 2 is 2
both conditions
despite so we write the expression like
this we wrote three and one plus two
let's move the camera a bit okay that's
better
expanding the brackets gives us x
squared plus X plus two x plus two now
we can use grouping which we learnt in
the previous session considering these
two groups and taking the common factors
out this is what we get x times X plus
one is this group and two times X plus
one is this group X plus one is common
to both the product and this would be
multiplied with X plus two there you go
we have factorize this down to X plus 1
times X plus 2
just remember these two conditions sum
is B and the product is AC using the
same concept try and factorize this
polynomial x squared plus X minus 6
hopefully you have the right answer
let's solve it together and have a look
here a is 1 B also is 1 and C the
constant is -6 we have to split the
coefficient of the middle term which is
1 the sum of the two numbers is B which
equals 1 and the product of the two
numbers would be the product of a and C
1 multiplied by minus 6 is minus 6 to
find the two numbers all we do is try
out different products to get minus 6 1
x minus 6 is minus 6 but 1 plus minus 6
is not 1 ok let's try 2 x minus 3 this
is minus 6 but their sum is minus 1 not
1 minus 2 times 3 gives us minus 6 and
their sum is 1 which is X
what we want the two numbers would be -2
and 3 we split the coefficient of the
middle term and write it like this this
is the same as X we expand the brackets
and use grouping to factorize it the
first group can be written as x times X
minus 2 and the second one can be
written as 3 times X minus 2 now it's
easy the term common to both the product
is X minus 2 multiplying it with X plus
3 completes the expression we have our
factors don't worry this is easy we only
need to do three things
split the coefficient of the middle term
then expand and then group that gives us
the factors just to be sure that you
have understood the technique well try
factorizing this expression this is the
answer you should get the two factors
are 4 x + 1 + 3 X - 4 and the two
numbers you would have got would be - 16
+ 3 if you felt this session was a bit
too fast-paced please go through the
background tutorials which will give you
an in-depth understanding of
factorization